my archeological team actually is very
unique because I'm the only ecologist
and the other members are computer
scientists software engineers and
applied mathematicians we are like a
crime scene investigation with patiently
document with latest technology the
construction technique of a planet today
I'm going to talk about one of the most
exciting experience in my academic life
that is climbing the great planet I've
been fascinated by planet Egypt since
the time of energy a high school but the
reason why I climb the pyramid is not
just in a fascination the purpose of the
climbing of the planet for ecologist is
to obtain data so the traditional
approach to the study of racial Egypt is
like you know jigsaw puzzle we ecologist
collects the data from the excavation
site and then start to describe the past
but as a consequence actual survey data
is less frequently updated this is a
particularly tool for the planet at Giza
and also such traditional documentation
is done by line drawing which does not
be pleasant actual state of the monument
such a critical documentation only focus
on external part of the planet and in a
space such as chamber and you know the
space and corridor so no observation of
the core of the planet has been made
supplies ngey there is a three kind of
in all hypotheses probably in the curve
the pyramid may consist of horizontal
valence blocked or some ejector just be
deep maybe has a step planet or the core
may build by what we called an
acceleration layer but we don't know
which is true the input
of the study of the cost lecture will be
related to the construction technique
namely the type of the lump ancient
Egyptian employed for example if ramp is
straight maybe this is suitable for
setting arrange the block or if a planet
has a cost step probably in a zig zag
lump will be you know the EGD set on the
cost up or implement has a layer we
called on a spinal amber up clamp would
be appropriate for that but we don't
know which is quite but luckily there is
a place we can actually observe the cost
lecture of the pyramid but which is
located 80 meter from the ground so you
have to actually climb up the pyramid it
was a you know the quite experience for
me because this is the ancient monument
you have to climb without PTIN and the
safety log after two and a half hours so
we did in this area this is how open
space called knotch and interestingly
this not has a kind of you know crevice
in the West so that led to another small
open space called cave so we really
wanted to document this area however we
could not actually bring any stabbing
equipment such as you know laser scanner
because there's ask Allah is heavy and
big but we had to somewhat a make
archaeological documentation with the
video footage my archaeological team
actually is very unique because I am the
only ecologist and the other members are
computer scientists software engineers
and applied mathematicians and computer
scientists came up with idea to employ
structure from motion technique so this
technique allows you to stitch image
from the video footage for the
reconstruction of our study area
20 minutes video footage what splatting
to 300,000 image rain and this is our
result so this is a first decoding of
the these areas so let's compare our
data with previous surveys so whether
this is horizontally orange block or
stepped color or layer so this is a also
photographic section a produced from our
3d data as you can see here it showed
totally different structure and you may
wonder what this you know the Cape like
so I presume this is a place ancient
Egyptian used for packing in feeling of
sand and also devvra's this is actually
well known technique in ancient Egypt
called chamber methods so which apply to
you know the construction of the temples
and the cities and also the pyramid in
in a delayed period Middle Kingdom
pyramids but this technique accumulates
a walk in d'marco bleah economical way
but we didn't know this technique
actually applied in all the kingdom
planets probably this is a first one so
finally where is the top of the Great
Pyramid after the cramming of fibroids
so again we used the video footage and
digital image for structure from motion
process and multi booster system and
this is a the first detailed plan of the
top of the planet which can tell us lot
of information but by their nature this
image cannot be Pleasant 3d information
so again our computer scientist came up
the idea new display method of 3d called
picot so this is a carelessness map and
warmer color means shorter distance from
viewer and the cooler color means longer
distance and the peak it I also can
indicate rich
and the valley which is also very
important for our clerical analysis and
finally this is our 3d data we are like
you know the crime scene investigation
we patiently document with latest
technology and then began to demonstrate
as a construction technique of a
particular area such as top of the
planet and area on the north end okay
and I hope I can continue to collect the
data of important areas around the
Pyramid of Giza so eventually the
reality of the pyramid will be deleted
which also tell us the arity of the
civilization thank
you